da meine haare momentan überhaupt nicht
klar gehen weil ich seit über einem
monat nicht beim friseur war habe ich
mir einen sombrero bestellt damit ihren
negativen nachricht starten
denn das beste unterbrochen heute seien
gar nicht die rechte an diesen
verdammten lied habe wenn ihr euch also
das beste tipp der woche anschauen wollt
dann schaut bei mir auf tik tok vorbei
ich hasse den sommer jetzt schon
[Musik]
ich muss sagen ich kann ich eigentlich
gar nicht so lustig der einzige grund
wieso ich voller dieser app habe weil
ich ein bisschen so aussieht wie einer
von harry potter check
[Musik]
mich sowas auf meiner homepage angezeigt
was mache ich mit meinem leben
[Musik]
merkt man das nicht schnell
aber nicht beim friseur herein check
leute ich mache jetzt auch mal hell ein
check uns war
[Musik]
ist meine harmlos blockbuster qualität
so fangen wir erstmal mit den grundlagen
das für dich leider das war bei mir beim
abi exakt gewisses gefühl je der nur mit
diesem youtube kanal von diesem simple
mit gelernt
[Musik]
das wasser hat
den papa ich hab noch ein tanzender
studie zu den seen klar ja ganz toll
erwischt nun nicht mehr so gelacht bei
der ubs gibt es ist tatsächlich ist
einfach so nein danke
es ist einfach die wahrheit oft habe ich
in meinem leben echt pech gehabt
muss ich sagen aber mein großes special
leben ist das erlebe ich jetzt gerade
döner ein euro genau wenn ich schon
immer dann mach menschen als arschlöcher
kombi nun allerdings zu einem tick tock
meine lieben freunde was ich auf der
plattform gesehen habe und ich habe es
mir wirklich 34 mal am stück angeschaut
ich habe immer nicht verstanden was die
gesagt haben
obwohl das deutsche ja die reihen zu
schließen
das ist ganz geschlossen wenn man diesen
preisen schneidet in das mache ich echt
weil irgendwann hatten wollen ob die
spritzen wissenschaften greift muss die
kannst also kann man glaube ich die
beste geschäfte haben
die seinem fleisch mehr ausrichten und
gestern freundlich gegner
wenn ihr
standard aber was sie sich unterhalten
dann schreibt es mir immer gern und in
die kommentare
hallo und willkommen sein dass
präsentationen über den zweiten
weltkrieg also mortara ich verstehe dich
nicht kannst du lauter reden jessica
kannste offen so zu tun als erster in
der präsentation interessieren ich will
es nicht sagen aber das ist die wahrheit
[Musik]
das ist mega trucks wir haben dort alle
schüler während eines xoom
klassenunterricht ihres screens
synchronisiert und haben doch eine dvd
logo darüber fahren lassen
das mega heftig was auch heftig ist ist
allerdings die dass die nächste personen
bezogen auf einen zoom klassen
unterrichts meeting konferenz kol
[Musik]
ja es gibt halt solche leute die dann so
krasse ingenieure sind und sich so was
überlegen so mit dem handy
dann gibt es halt auch die deutschen
begriffe wie vor menschen mit schwächen
immerhin extreme alexa wie vielleicht
schaffen wir auf dieses video 10.000
sonst ist es eine schlechte community
ja
ähnlich hat deine alexanders gesagt wie
feel like schaffen wir auf das heutige
video was mein kampf und macht wenn ich
die leine fallen muss
das war sehr süß aber ist ob wirklich
nichts das nächste tik tok was süßigkeit
bei das ist das nomen von süss sprachen
lernen will
[Musik]
mit den ganzen hunden der quarantäne
da will ich das
bis 2100 durchziehen guten tag wir
heissen sie mit ok danke und die
nachnahme mit gab ja mit karl das habe
ich und die nachnahme mein nachname ist
mit k
können sie das buchstabieren itk okay
ist das richtig so nein mehr etc
ok also ich stehe mit unseren breiten
das ist doch nicht schwer dieses spiel
hat sich spiel das auch mal ein paar
sekunden später frau wir schauen genau
armer junge
[Musik]
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
die arme ente
sie ist nicht echt android oder ist es
wirklich gut gemacht wirklich sehr sehr
gut ab
auf alle die die serie gesehen haben
denken es nicht gerade so dass ist der
synchronsprecher
[Musik]
nein
da ist meine liebe freunde ist ein neuer
filter auf instagram und zwar bekommen
wenn dort mehrere images angezeigte muss
anhand der im modus erraten was das für
ein star ist also was für ein name sich
dahinter verbirgt und ich hab schon
natürlich nicht nehmen lassen das ganze
auch mal zu testen und dann dann besteht
[Musik]
der besen jetzt ganz kurz innehalten
jedes mal wenn der zubau lauf markt wird
mich das leben ist kurz habe keine angst
risiko
warum
bekomme ich sowas angezeigt und warum
bekommt ihr mich eigentlich angezeigt
also es ist ja peinlichkeit pur
breaking news
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
das ist ja so frech das ist ja so frech
stellt euch mal vor ihr würdet das
theoretisch bei euren besten freund oder
am besten freundin und dem engsten
partner machen
yes
ich stelle mir diese frage zwar relativ
häufig aber auch hier frage ich mich
wieder warum bekomme ich sowas angezeigt
aber gut kommen wir zum letzten tag das
heutige video klein
[Musik]
euro
kein
dieses mal gelacht an der stelle mich
dass häufig wie jetzt allerdings auch
beenden meine lieben freunde wenn euch
die heutige politik der künstler
gefallen hat das kann einen daumen hoch
unter dem video eda schreibt nämlich
bereichen sagt unten in die kommentare
was ihr bei diesem einen ticker
verstanden habt wo die deutsch
gesprochen haben aber irgendwie auch
nicht
ziemlich mysteriös allerdings befinden
wir uns jetzt auch im auto um meine
lieben freunde wie auch sagen ihm freude
wir sind ich hab keine freunde aber gut
wenn ihr darauf klickt könnte ihm einen
kanal abonnieren auf den smiley und wenn
ihr hier darauf könnt ihr euch ein
anderes video anschauen
also mach das mal weil ich bin ein opfer